[Music]
it was the day
uber's business model came to a sudden
stop
drivers celebrating victory over the
ride-hailing platform at the uk's top
court last month
after judges ruled that uber must
provide workers rights to
thousands of drivers i'm just so
delighted thrilled and
relieved that this day has arrived and
we've got the right judgment
now uber has implemented that ruling
offering to pay minimum wage
holiday pay and pension contributions
today is an important day for all
drivers in the uk
and the reason for that is because from
today any driver who earns
on the uber platform and that's over 70
000 drivers in total
will be able to be paid for
holiday time they'll be enrolled in a
pension
and they'll be able to earn at least the
national living wage as a floor
and not a ceiling critics however say
the benefits are based on time drivers
spend paired with a customer
not time spent waiting for work despite
this from the court the judgment also
upholds the finding of the employment
tribunal that for the purposes of the
legislation
the claimant's working time was not
limited as uber had argued
to periods when they were actually
driving passengers to their destinations
it also included any period when the
driver was logged into the uber app
in the relevant territory analysts say
the ruling could have huge ramifications
for the exploding gig economy
not just drivers but cyclists too
not just the uk but further afield as
governments
wrestle with the distinction between
workers and contractors
for now though uber could be taking a
trip back to court soon
over claims its new changes still don't
comply with employment law
and hopefully we will get james farrar
you just saw him in the report former
uber driver who brought that legal case
on the line in in just a moment in the
meantime the eu is
also looking at bringing in regulations
to support geek
economy workers so could the development
in britain spill over to europe let's
bring in our business correspondent
conrad busen
i'm just telling you that about one in
10 people in the eu works in the gig
economy as you know the eu wants to
improve their lives how significant
could this development in the uk be for
the eu
it's very significant you know i have
the total number for you 24 million
europeans at least
are working uh or work in the gig
economy uh for at least three million
among them
the income from these jobs is the only
source of income
so for them it's very uh important and
as we just heard
not only for people working for ride
hailing services like uber but also food
delivery services in a number of court
cases in europe for example in italy
in spain but many more countries there
are court cases pending
judges have been very unwilling to grant
the companies
any exception from the way how the
workers are seen and what kind of
privileges
they should get or what kind of
protection they should get
also of course next to the question
whether or not a person should be seen
as an employee
this other question becomes more and
more important when are geek workers
actually at work when they log into the
app
or when they drive around passengers and
when they drive around the food
deliveries for example
this question is going to become more
and more crucial and
obviously in the case in the uk um
uber wanted to be quick by accepting
this compromise
before a court would say hey you have to
grant
the people who are working for you
payments also
when they're waiting in the car when
they're looking for jobs
all right so there's still questions
that certainly within europe need to be
clarified
conrad boson thank you so much
you